brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition hey guys my name is Jess and
it is Tuesday December the eighth today
and she's mad at thinking Kristen Chuck
three has been confirmed sort of
probably accidentally here's the latest
on that our website called other side
cheese calm launched with a timer
presumably set to reveal the game in
five days time unfortunately that whole
plan a separate page on the site has
already gone live which features the
logo System Shock three the game was in
development from boston-based other side
entertainment corner earth founder of
the original system shock developer
Looking Glass Studios is listed as the
founder of other side other notable
figures include Joe fielder whose resume
includes BioShock Infinite and bloom box
on November 12 night dive studio said
that they obtained full rights to the
system shock franchise and are working
on a full remake at the time they said
they may partner with another company to
do so but it's unclear to what extent
they are involved in System Shock 3 the
future of clothes shopping is here and
it's arrived on Xbox one where you can
paste cut out clothes on your body and
pretend that that's a viable way to try
on clothes a new Xbox one app called the
mall will give you a hilarious if not
great reason to turn on your connect you
can use the free up to pick clothes to
Trigon and then see them gone perfectly
to your body sort of as you can imagine
the app isn't perfect there are a number
of bugs and not all the items can be
tried on virtually that said you can
complete your purchase using the power
tag up if you really like a look of it
that a bright red have reportedly said
they want cyberpunk 2077 to come out at
the end of 2016 the witcher 3 developer
originally announced cyberpunk 2077 in
october 2012 and told us at the time
that they wouldn't be discussing the
game until 2017 at the earliest yes a
whole five years after the original
reveal that said game reactor germany
who allegedly have a source close to the
studio reports that they're aiming for a
late
16 launch although the game is presently
only set to release on PC the source
also suggested that a ps4 and xbox one
release is cooked more than likely let
me know down in the comments if you're
keen to play system shock 3 and hit the
games / or we've got news on a destiny
patch and a new GTA 5 mode that is all
the good stuff I have you today but as
always let me know what matters to you
and lkt same time tomorrow